we've recently been making videos
discussing how apple's m1x max will
dominate the market
due to some unique technological
advantages
even despite many windows chip and
laptop makers
including intel themselves rushing in
to make arm and risk five base chips of
their own
to compete with apple but there's one
question left unanswered and i think
this one is on the mind of many people
out there
how will these upcoming m1x chips affect
the
gaming segment of the pc market and
that's exactly what i'm gonna answer
in this video with a bunch of various
perspectives
and pieces of evidence that basically
show that gaming on the mac
is only going uphill from here on out so
let's get started
as all of you guys know apple's m1 max
have been amazing
especially the m1 macbook air which is
an incredible value for only 950 bucks
on amazon
giving you premium build quality best in
class battery life
great performance reliability cooling
awesome speakers and more the only issue
is that gaming
isn't that great with two major
downsides being limited graphics
performance
and limited game selection but even
despite that
many windows laptop users have actually
been switching to m1 max
and absolutely loving them and even with
limited gaming support
we've been able to play games like world
of warcraft with great performance
and even windows games like grand theft
auto 5 and the witcher 3
using methods like crossover and
parallels 16
but of course with the settings turned
down so
imagine what's going to happen when
apple fixes gaming
with the new m1x macbook pros it's
basically gonna be
a laptop revolution but before i explain
how apple is gonna do this
let me quickly discuss how gaming was on
macs
before the m1 chip was released way back
in june of 2020 we got our hands on the
16 inch macbook pro
with the brand new 5600m gpu from amd
which was a very expensive 800
upgrade compared to the base model but
it drastically improved graphics
performance
being twice as powerful as the base
5300m we were even able to use bootcamp
to install windows 10
and play games like fortnite and call of
duty warzone at an
average of around 144 fps with decent
settings
which meant that you could hook it up to
an actual 144hz
gaming monitor and have an awesome
gaming setup
this level of gaming performance was
something we've never seen on a macbook
before
the only issue was that you'd have to
spend at least 3 200 on this model
and that's while keeping the base 6 core
cpu the base 16 gigs of ram
and the base 512 gigs of storage but now
we're expecting the m1x macbook pros and
the crazy thing
is that they're going to destroy that
5600m model
in terms of performance for a much lower
price
in terms of cpu performance the m1 chip
already outperforms the best 16-inch
intel
i9 chip in everything from single core
performance
to multi-core performance which is a bit
crazy to believe but with the 10 core
m1x chip that'll be packing
eight high performance cores and two
efficiency cores
we're expecting multi-core performance
to jump up to over
14 000 points almost as good
as the current 16 core mac pro and in
terms of graphics performance it gets
even better according to mark german the
most reliable apple leaker out there
the m1x chip will come with either 16 or
32 graphic scores depending on the price
and based on my own performance
calculations the 16 core gpu base model
for 2400 will actually
outperform the crazy
5600m graphics option which is hard to
believe
but it's most likely gonna happen but to
make it even better
you need to keep in mind that the m1x's
gpu is still going to be
integrated into the same soc package
which means that it's also going to get
the massive advantage of being able to
use
the unified memory architecture so
instead of data having to travel back
and forth between the cpu
and the discrete gpu everything happens
together within the same
chip being much more efficient and
greatly reducing latency
which will further improve performance
and make everything more reliable so
there will no longer be
amd graphics driver issues to worry
about and on top of that
i personally believe that apple will be
adding hardware
ray tracing to the m1x chip and here's
why that makes sense
first off apple's been working on ray
tracing since their 2019
wwdc event and they've been improving on
it every year since then
especially at last month's wwdc where
apple's made some groundbreaking changes
like allowing single pass rendering
hybrid rendering
using tile functions on apple silicon
extending the limits of
data size when ray tracing and
supporting
motion blur and ray tracing to make
motion look more natural
and the second reason why i think
hardware ray tracing is coming
is because this is the first apple
silicon chip
that will be powerful enough to actually
run games with ray tracing enabled but
to make everything even better
everything that i just said applies to
the 16 core gpu
we haven't even gotten into the upgraded
32 core version of the m1x
based on my calculations it should be
getting around 80 to 90
000 points in the geekbench 5 metal test
which is close to as good
as the vega 2 gpu in the mac pro
which was able to hit 60fps while gaming
at
6k resolution which is mind-blowing
that level of performance has never been
seen before
on a macbook and even that 32 core gpu
should only be around 300 to 400 to
upgrade to
so likely a total of 27 or 2 800
for the 16 inch macbook pro compared to
the current
5600 mgpu which brings it to a total of
3200
for the intel model but then when we
consider the base
16 core m1x model it's gonna have
similar performance to the 5600m
but for 800 less and that 16 core
will likely also be available on the 14
inch macbook pro
for around 2200 total so what i'm trying
to say
is that for the first time ever
consumers will be getting
aaa gaming levels of graphics
performance on a mac
for a really good price on top of that
the m1x macbook pros are expected to
come with an hdmi port
which will likely be hdmi 2.1
which is now the most popular port for
gaming monitors and modern tvs
so this could be a hint that apple wants
to take gaming very seriously
on top of that the laptop market has
been quickly expanding recently
because of the massive gpu shortages
which have basically forced users to buy
gaming laptops
instead of building custom desktop pcs
so if apple can give us great gaming
performance while also giving us a
premium and reliable laptop for everyday
use
with best-in-class battery life apple
will dominate the laptop
and gaming space and apple themselves
are expecting this to happen
since they're adding an extra mini led
display supplier
to keep up with the high demand for
these m1x macbook pros
the only issue that remains is having
support for decent games
with the biggest problem being the fact
that bootcamp just doesn't work with
apple silicon max
so you can't play the wide variety of
windows games out there
and on top of that there's the issue of
games with hardware drm
level and tai chi systems not running at
all so let's discuss the solutions to
those craig federighi has already
mentioned that
apple silicon macs are fully capable of
running the armed version of windows
it's simply up to microsoft to license
it and then
m1 max will literally be able to run
windows using bootcamp and the good news
about that
is that microsoft has been putting a ton
of work into the brand new
windows 11 on arm they've recently
announced arm 64 ec
which is basically the rosetta 2 for
windows automatically
translating and running code with native
performance
on arm chips that took a ton of work to
pull off
and if you're wondering why they would
do this it's because microsoft
themselves
are rumored to be working on their own
arm-based chip designs
for their surface line of pcs to compete
with apple's m1 max
so if they're going to have their own
arm-based computers
they need windows 11 on arm to be as
good as possible
so i fully expect apple silicon max to
gain
boot camp support in the near future and
now discussing the issue of games with
anti-cheat software not running on m1
max
that's obviously going to change very
soon because the entire industry
is headed towards using arm and risk 5
based chips
including microsoft intel qualcomm
samsung amd and even nvidia's rumored
arm
gaming laptop so if those laptops will
be able to play games with anti-cheat
systems
apple's max will as well so i fully
expect that issue to be resolved
within the next year or two and finally
there's been a good amount of evidence
that apple themselves
are investing and preparing for a huge
gaming push
so i think there's a chance that they'll
in some shape or form
be marketing these m1x macbook pros as
gaming laptops i dug through a bunch of
wwc
2021 developer videos to see what gaming
improvements apple has made and i found
that they've redesigned and fully
optimized the game center
to make it work much better they've made
huge advancements in terms of game
controller support
including supporting the ps5 and xbox
series x controllers
they've added a 15 second buffering
in-game recording
feature and much more like ray tracing
improvements and on top of all of that
there have been rumors that apple is
preparing a special event this fall
that would be focused on gaming with a
new gaming console
and a new gaming controller being
released they've also been rumored to be
working with well-known
gaming companies to bring aaa games to
apple devices
which will obviously run great on the
m1x macbook pros
one of my twitter followers also
mentions sarah rogers
who is hiring for apple's gpu software
team
specifically focused on creating the
biggest gaming platform
in the world so this shows that apple's
own employees are excited about gaming
so to wrap up this entire video apple's
m1x max will come with more than enough
performance
to handle both mac os and windows games
very well
right off the bat using methods like
crossover and parallels
16. but on top of that it won't be long
until we get official windows 11 on arm
support
using boot camp as well as the ability
to play multiplayer online games
that use drm anti-cheat systems that
will soon be
rewritten to support arm-based chips so
basically
buying an m1x macbook pro is gonna be a
no-brainer
because you'll be getting essentially
the best laptop ever made
when you combine the premium build
quality the features like great speakers
the performance the battery life the
reliability
and the great gaming performance as well
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one and
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video